Me,
Kosuke-kun, I'm also researching an algorithm that can find the true ending in any romance game in a short time
.
Dakuahn In general, it's said that you choose an option in a romance game to proceed with the scenario. Depending on how you choose, the
ending will change.
There are 10,000 different ways
to choose.
Well, if you choose 50 countermeasures, there will be
about 7,000 hits.
In other words, love games may be np-hard in computational complexity theory.
Is love games mp-hard
? Is there an effective method for searching
?
Recently, there was a paper that proved that Manny and Parker are difficult
to mp.
Using the fact that you can find a route
No matter what kind of color game you play, you can collect all the newcomers
in an instant.My guess is that it's impossible, but if it's something close to that
, I
might cut it.